I'd like to believe that critical
thinking is woven into pretty much
everything we do here on the Rubin
report but today's show is gonna have an
even keener focus on this
all-encompassing topic at the end of the
day whether we're talking about politics
religion or current events it all boils
down to critical thinking the definition
of which is quote the objective analysis
and evaluation of an issue in order to
form a judgment end quote
can we really look at the world the way
it truly is not the way we want it to be
can we set aside our faith based hopes
to analyze real world problems or is
faith actually a part of the problem as
opposed to being the solution each week
I try to have conversations that exist
in this space without resorting to ad
hominem attacks and straw man arguments
that guiding principle is fully based in
critical thinking and moral reasoning
joining me this week is Peter Bogosian
philosophy instructor critical thinker
and author of a manual for creating
atheists Peter's book is a really
incisive clear take on why critical
thinking is important how faith-based
thinking can be dangerous and also
relates what you can do to spread ideas
based on fact and reason with your
friends and family he writes in an
understandable and relatable style on
topics that many were afraid to touch on
even with the people closest to them he
gives the reader the very tools to help
people trapped by faith-based thinking
yes I did say help their help is exactly
what I believe is needed in this
situation when your beliefs aren't based
in reason and critical thinking it
creates a space where extremism can
creep in this of course isn't holdin to
one religion or ideology any time you
throw reason and fact out the window to
trade it with ideas that aren't provable
you create the very breeding ground that
extremism needs to spread it's not a
coincidence that in places where gays
women and minorities are treated poorly
are also the places where religion has
often been a substitute for clear moral
thinking by the way we here in the West
could do a much better job of this
ourselves I know we're more focused on
Islamic extremism on this show but there
all kinds of extremism in the world you
can't deal with any of these ideologies
with half-truths and by shooting the
messengers you must deal with them by
looking at them head-on and tackling the
ideologies with better ideas and moral
clarity we live in a time when religious
extremism is on the rise I'm gonna guess
that we probably don't have many
religious extremists watching this show
so I don't know how much of an effect I
can have on those people the people that
I can have an effect on however is you
guys people out there from every walk of
life from all over the globe who want to
do the work of finding out what brings
us together not what tears us apart I
firmly believe that critical thinking is
the solution
critical thinking doesn't care about
your race your sexuality or your
nationality it is a road map to solving
serious issues and combatting
superstitious thinking that has led to
many real-world problems much of the
right in America is led by Christian
religious ideology much of the left
while not guided by religion has become
as dogmatic in its beliefs between the
two is where most clear minded free
thinking people live it's what my guest
on next week's show Ali Rizvi refers to
as the new center I think by letting go
of our superstitions and focusing on
real solutions we can change the world
for the better either that or we can
leave it up to the zealots after all the
world is what you make of it